anyway here now is Virginia governor
Glenn young and Governor great to have
you back sir how are you
John thank you for having me thank you
for covering this I think this is the
most important election in the nation we
have a chance to really stand up yes for
common sense conservative values and
just 24 months ago Virginia was a state
that was completely dominated by the
Democrats and we swept our Statewide
elections in 2021 we flipped our house
and now's our chance to finish the work
to hold our house flip our Senate and
really get Virginia in overdrive you
know on the ballot Sean are really Clear
Choices a choice between low taxes or
tax and spend a choice between
empowering parents or letting the
teachers unions and bureaucrats raise
your children a choice between back in
the blue or allowing them to continue to
demean and demoralize law enforcement
and finally Sean a choice between
running a state with a real purpose that
we understand we work four four
Virginians as opposed to telling them
what to do all the time with mandates I
think virginian's done great I mean
listen Sean we we started out bottom
third in the nation when I came in and
job growth and over the last 20 months
we've risen to third in the nation in
job growth we've got more Virginians
working than ever we're continuing to
drive for expectations of excellence in
our schools we're back in the blue so
now we're on the ballot and we have got
to hold our house and flip our Senate
and that's why we're pushing so hard for
early voting we have a we have 41 days
left of early voting and then of course
election day on November the 7th there
were 500
000 Virginians who voted for Winsome
Sears and Jason miaras and me in 2021
that didn't cut out and vote in the
midterms last year and so we are pushing
hard to get Republicans off the
sidelines get to secure your vote
virginia.com make a plan to vote early
and let's win this thing you know I'm
glad you're talking about early voting
I've been saying to Republicans you've
got to get over it's not the system I
want I want paper ballots uh election
day to be a national holiday I want
partisan observers watching the vote
count all day when the polls close watch
the vote counting all night declare a
winner I want signature identification
voter ID chain of custody controls
updated voter rolls but partisan
observers are crucial but that's not the
system we have and I think you're being
realistic and Republicans conservatives
need to get this message you better deal
with the system we're stuck with and the
Democrats they have mastered early
voting Republicans have waited you can't
start election day down four or five
hundred thousand votes that expect to be
competitive similarly legal ballot
harvesting it's legal in many states
Democrats have mastered that now the RNC
has decided to go forward with bank your
vote I give them credit now they need to
get into the issue of legal ballot
harvesting in the states that allow it
otherwise they're not going to be
competitive in my view
yeah Sean and just to add voter having a
having a vote a picture ID to vote to
your list but on top of this what we of
course have seen is that Republicans
have stayed on the sidelines sometimes
and and miss miss it because they have a
sick child or there's a storm or
something happens at work and we've got
to get everybody out to vote and I will
say on the first day of early voting in
Prince William County which is one of
our big Battleground counties there were
74 percent more people who voted on the
first day of our ballot this year than
last year in our Congressional midterms
it's working we got to get people off
the sidelines that secure your
votevirginia.com and Sean we can win
this thing and show the nation that in
fact they state that just 24 months ago
was controlled by the progressive left
can truly change direction and Common
Sense conservative leadership and
policies work they work Sean this isn't
a moment of a philosophical debate this
is about promises made and Promises Kept
and Real Results well the the house of
delegates you have 49 Republicans 46
Democrats at the three vote margin for
Republicans five vacancies in the Senate
you got 22 Democrats 18 Republicans four
seat differences so it seems on paper
Within Reach so I urge everybody in the
Commonwealth of Virginia to pay
attention this will impact your life and
the life of you know generations to come
to be honest I hate to ask you this the
obvious question that you're getting
hammered with all the time but I
wouldn't be doing my job a lot of rumors
after this election you will consider
getting into the 2024 presidential
primary is there any truth to that have
you thought about it at all
Sean I've been totally focused on our
2023 elections and as you've just said
it is so important that we hold our
house and flip our Senate and in fact
you may have just seen Joe Biden came
out and said that he is now going to
fully weigh into our Virginia State
Legislative elections he sent one and a
half million dollars out of the DNC to
try to fund the other candidates who are
trying to run against our very good
slate of Republicans this has my full
attention and it deserves it we are
going to hold our house and flip our
Senate and show America that a state can
fully change direction I totally
completely agree uh the margin you won
by was spectacular I had written off the
Commonwealth of Virginia's just not
winnable for Republicans you proved me
wrong in a good way thank you hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else